[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 voici les principaux titres en
images de ce 27 avril 2010 est à plaisir
le personnel de l'hôpital jean martin
charcot s'est mis en grève illimitée
depuis hier pour contester un projet de
suppressions de postes et de réduction
du nombre de jours de congés pendant ce
temps elle en cours les travaux du
quartier est 17 mar en plein centre
ville se poursuivent
point d'étape de ce chantier d'envergure
et puis nous quitterons aussi 50 en
yvelines au cours de ce journal pour la
martinique cadre du prochain raid des
alizés nous verrons comment se préparent
les équipes yvelinoise à cette aventure
nature et solidaire
pour débuter ce journal le point sur les
chiffres du chômage dans les yvelines
qui ont été dévoilés hier pour mars pôle
emploi recense 93400 20 demandeurs
d'emploi une baisse de 0,5 pour cent par
rapport au mois de février mais une
hausse de 0 4% sur un an
à noter que sur la totalité du
territoire français le chômage a connu
en mars sa plus forte hausse en quatre
ans pour s'établir à 3,51 millions
social toujours et cette grève depuis
mercredi des personnels des hôpitaux de
plaisir après le centre hospitalier
charcot hier c'est aujourd'hui l'
hôpital gérontologique et médico-social
et qui était mobilisé les salariés
grévistes mettent en cause un plan de
restructuration prévu à l'horizon 2018
après la fusion des deux établissements
précision de mélanie poquet sur place
ils ont empêché le conseil de
surveillance de la gms l'hôpital
gérontologique et médico social de
plaisir
les salariés protestent contre la
suppression de postes
il se passe de choses il ya un plan de
licenciements envisagés par le biais
d'une privatisation de services
soignants 1 qui sont des ash au nombre
de 47 aujourd'hui et ces essais laisser
le début puisque demain il y à des
suppressions de lits qui sont annoncés
est ce qui fait qu il y aura aussi de
nouveaux des suppressions de postes mais
alors tous corps confondus
autre sujet de tension la fusion de
l'établissement avec l'hôpital charcot
au 1er janvier 2018
une fusion qui entraînera notamment une
même charte pour les deux centres sur le
temps de travail mais 47 postes c'est
quelque chose qui est décidé les 47 dont
fin de contrat dont vingt reprises
ça c'est pour la gms pour charcot pour
surtout pour la convergence des charters
et et rien n'est décidé on a simplement
dit et je comprends leur inquiétude
on a simplement dit aux représentants du
personnel que on ne pourrait pas avoir
une harmonisation massif par le haut
c'est rigoureusement impossible
actuellement 1200 agents travaillent à
la gms 700 à charcot les négociations
ont débuté au mois d'avril
le mouvement se poursuit les salariés
ont appelé à la grève illimitée
nous partons à l encours à présent ou la
rénovation du quartier 17 mars poursuit
depuis le mois de janvier plusieurs
chantiers d'envergure ayant débuté avec
la construction d'une nouvelle école de
musique ou encore le remplacement total
de l'ancienne dalle les travaux vont
durer tout de même un an les précisions
avec le reportage à de nickel nicolas
kirillovitch sur les images de camille
lambert
une rénovation à coups de marteaux
piqueurs et de pelleteuses bientôt les
notes de l'école de musique d'elancourt
s'imposeront dans le quartier 17 mar en
lieu et place de l'ancien centre
oecuménique
le nouveau bâtiment de 700 m² avec une
quinzaine de salles au total pourra
accueillir jusqu'à 500 élèves dans
l'école de musique on va avoir deux
salles qui sont des sales nouvelles qui
sont des salles d'éveil pour la musique
ou des tout petits vont pouvoir au plus
jeune âge commencer l'apprentissage de
la musique et ça c'est important
et puis après vous avez des salles de
cours des salles dédiées des salles des
petites salles qui sont par exemple pour
le piano pour la salle de percussions
qui l'a va avoir un traitement très
particulier sur ce nouveau quartier 17
mar la musique s'exportera même à
l'extérieur avec des gammes gravé sur la
dalle le sol est désormais recouverte
d'un enrobé rouge pour plus de sécurité
et assurer la circulation des personnes
à mobilité réduite
les travaux débutés en janvier doivent
profiter à l'ensemble des acteurs de la
vie locale
l'humain est au coeur de l'ensemble de
nos projets avec de l'intergénérationnel
de l'associatif
du la culture la possibilité de pouvoir
les gens qui sont donc en situation pmr
de pouvoir circuler correctement et
créer atterrir tout ça une véritable vie
un dynamisme qui va relancer l'activité
commerciale de notre d'arles
la fin des travaux est prévue pour le
premier trimestre 2010 8 pour un coût
total estimé à près de 5 millions
d'euros 66 % à la charge de
l'agglomération et le tiers restant à
celle d'elancourt la société dom expo
vient de présenter les nouveaux
aménagements extérieurs de son village
d'exposition situé aux abords de la
nationale 10 à coignières ce lieu où
sont installés plusieurs constructeurs
de maisons est comparable à un salon
permanent
il est tout de même implanté dans cette
ville depuis 1981 et les travaux ont
permis de remporter ce parcours de
visite
les précisions du directeur de dôme expo
de tous les points de passage on peut
voir à distance l'ensemble des pavillons
que l'on peut visiter
ça permet un accès plus aisé c'est plus
agréable c'est c'est plus champêtre
également avant c'était un peu plus
raide pu peu plus difficile aujourd'hui
on est aussi bien à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur des maisons
notre but c'est que ce soit un plaisir
que de venir visiter la fois visiter les
maisons à l'intérieur et les villages à
l'extérieur propos recueillis par
nicolas quere lovitz on quitte à présent
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le haras de la cense qui est
située à rochefort en yvelines est
réputé pour son approche éthologique il
vient de publier un livre pour dévoiler
ses techniques distiller ses conseils
il y est question d'écouté de respect de
l'animal
camille lambert
[Musique]
totalement vrai papier il serait donc
entre wilko emmanuel c'est une histoire
qui dure depuis une dizaine d'années des
mois de travail pour arriver à établir
cette complicité une méthode celle du
haras de la cense on travaille avec un
animal donc
il faut connaître là dessus il a un peu
différent nous danser fonctionnement il
a des modes de communication qui lui
sont propres donc il faut les apprendre
et ensuite essayer de communiquer avec
lui pour lui faire comprendre qu'on a
envie de partage avec lui depuis les
années 2000 le haras base son éducation
sur la compréhension et la confiance
précurseur dans ce domaine il a résumé
sa méthode dans un livre ponctuée de
théorie et d'exercices pratiques
sortie le 20 avril il s'adresse à tous
passionnés professionnels ou amateurs
un livre de référence donc on peut
rentrer dans pioche est allé un peu un à
moi l'un par la bad boy à ce chapitre
mais c'est surtout un livre qui transmet
de la connaissance de la pédagogie et
qui donne les outils
donc on souhaite que tu fasses diffuser
le plus largement petit part que ça
améliorera la relation entre la mutuelle
c'est vraiment une synthèse sur
l'éthologie sur les principes
d'éducation des chevaux et puis après
128 exercice une méthode progressive de
manière à transmettre plus le plus
facilement à chaque couple cavalier
cheval une quarantaine de spécialistes a
participé à l'élaboration de cet ouvrage
le haras propose également des stages
avec ses intervenants le lieu sera
ouvert au grand public lors de ces
rencontres
du 15 au 17 septembre prochain
sport et solidarité c'est l'objectif de
ce raid des alizés une compétition
féminine qui se déroulera du 14 au 19
novembre prochain
en martinique soixante dix équipes
composées chacune de trois participantes
qui vont prendre le départ de cette
aventure de 7 et de ses différentes
épreuves
et parmi elles des habitantes de bois
d'arcy mickaël millero les a rencontré
ses deux voisines ont une âme
d'aventurière et veulent le prouve et
flore faille et véronique dubois deux
habitants de bois d'arcy veulent
participer à l'édition 2010 est du raid
des alizés une compétition 100 %
féminine organisée en martinique
l'idée a été lancée par flore la
sportive a déjà disputé l'épreuve en
2016 un dernière j'avais suivi un peu à
ce qu'elle avait fait et puis cette
année elle me l'a proposé et donc j'y ai
réfléchi parce que ça demande réflexion
quand même de s'investir dans ce type de
projet et
et puis je me suis décidé à le faire
puisque voilà j'ai une année transitoire
dans ma vie j'ai 40 ans cette année
et là je me suis dit pas chouette il
faut que je prenne des challenge est
donc voilà je lui ai dit oui pour
pouvoir réaliser les cinq jours
d'épreuves et terminer le plus haut
possible les deux arcisienne s'entraîne
plusieurs fois par semaine
courir forcément est le plus gros du
travail se fait dans le travail du
dénivelé est pour moi le kayak en
martinique a beaucoup de dénivelés on
sait pas dans quelles proportions et on
va en avoir mais c'est sûr il y en aura
je me met progressivement et puis avec
des aides balleux expérience aussi de
fleurs parce qu'elle est très sportive
du coup elle m'apporte beaucoup vu cela
questionne et puis j'ai voilà je
questionne aussi le tournoi tous les
sportifs pour ce qui serait mieux pour
moi pour me préparer pour participer ces
deux têtes brûlées doivent collecter
8500 euros d'ici le 1er septembre pour
le moment cette équipe baptisée mnm smad
elle-même sonara côté que 1500 euros un
défi de plus pour les deux athlètes
troisième volet de notre dossier
consacré cette semaine aux mariages et
nous allons voir que le secteur se porte
toujours bien sur le plan économique
entre le lieu elle est tenue les
décorations encore elle le repas les
couples y consacrent autour de 8000
euros en moyenne en france
michael et demi d'eau dans un mariage il
n'y a pas que les bulles de champagne
qui peuvent faire tourner la tête le
prix aussi la priorité numéro une pour
les mariés sélectionner le lieu dans les
yvelines un business s'est développé
celui des salles de prestige on retrouve
des dizaines de dieu à des prix pouvant
aller de 5000 à 20000 euros pour une
soirée l'un des plus connus l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay un domaine cisterciens
construire xiième siècle pour se payer
cette part d'histoire il faut faire
chauffer la carte bleue
une centaine d'individus il faut compter
un ticket moyen
si je peux parler ainsi en termes
hôtelier a minima aux alentours d'une
centaine d'euros pouvoir aller jusqu'à
150 euros à 150 euros par personne
bon nombre de jeunes mariés se sacrifie
pour pouvoir s'offrir l'abbaye des vaux
de cernay
c'est un événement unique dans leur vie
donc ils savent aussi faire la part des
choses parfois même emprunté lourdement
pour se faire plaisir à l'abbaye
l'abbaye accueille aujourd'hui entre 50
et 70 mariages chaque année certains
clients n'hésitent pas à parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres pour venir fêter
le plus beau jour de leur vie
le bouche à oreille fonctionne très bien
m'a beaucoup de mariages américain
beaucoup de mariages libanais la
communauté libanaise a mis le pied à
l'abbaye il ya quelques années on les
mariages généralement très somptueux qui
s'étendent généralement sur deux voire
trois jours
autre élément incontournable d'un
mariage les fleurs dans le département
les mariés et leurs familles peuvent
dépenser entre 500 et 1500 euros pour se
faire une place sur ce marché ultra
concurrentiel ce fleuriste implantée à
villepreux n'hésite pas à suivre les
dernières tendances
ces derniers temps surtout vous n'avez
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui se sont
mis en place dans la décoration on est
vraiment sur une mode qui est sûre du
champêtre
une mode qui est sûre du naturel du
romantique les mariés sont vraiment
friand de petites décorations de détails
un souci du détail qui est un prix 1000
euros pour un panier moyen dans cet
établissement
un coût qui s'explique en grande partie
par le temps qu'il faut pour réaliser le
bouquet parfait 10 à 15 minutes en
moyenne et surtout trouver les idées qui
feront la différence le jour j un
bouquet réussi dans un mariage c'est une
excellente associations de couleurs avec
un très beau camaïeu de couleurs des
couleurs qui s'associe très bien et
après le choix des fleurs le choix des
fleurs et est important parce que ça va
apporter ça va apporter le
le relief la forme une fois les fleurs
sélectionner les mariés devront
également ajouter les traditionnels
faire part la robe de mariée les
animations au total le budget de cette
journée grains peut rapidement pour
atteindre les 15000 euros en moyenne
pour cent convives sûrement le jour le
plus heureux mais aussi le plus coûteux
de leur vie dernier volet de ce dossier
demain et pour refermer ce journal à un
mot de la projection proposée vendredi
au ciné c'est à l encours à 20h30 vous
pourrez découvrir corporate et de
nicolas s'isole avec notamment lambert
wilson l'histoire d'une brillante
responsable des ressources humaines qui
doivent faire face à la pression de sa
hiérarchie et de l'inspection de travail
après un drame survenu dans cette
entreprise le scénariste du film sera
présent pour un échange avec la salle
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal les
programmes se poursuivre sur notre
antenne demain vendredi à 18 heures vous
avez rendez vous avec nicolas qui rit le
vide pour le traditionnel hebdo avec son
invité pour commenter l'actualité de la
semaine le journal quant à lui revient
mardi aux horaires habituels très bon
week-end prolongé
[Musique]